hold a dream as women because like you
only get passionate love for like two
three years maybe that's what my dad
always told maybe I know she's looking
at two three my dad said at most two
three years yeah and so what do you give
it six months no I'm saying I'm like
only two three years yeah that's it for
sure yeah
lifetime let's go yeah but that's the
thing because you know modern women have
been raised on rom-coms and and Disney
movies and so you guys think that you
know life is a Disney movie and a
rom-com and it's like no it's actually
no you're in a 10-year relationship how
long would you say that the honeymoon
phase like the honeymoon when does it go
into a more
a three and three and a half years maybe
like okay after three four years it's
like okay now we're just we're coasting
in this yeah we're in this groove do you
know what I mean and so there are dips
and there are like you know apexes and
the dips and then apexes and then
coasting but yeah that that I want to
see you every day and have sex with you
five times a day type love does not last
it just doesn't it does ah where show me
if you have four wives
you just around the market sister wow
two for once but we're getting closer
getting close to 40 every day
yeah no I just think here that that
whole
um and I think that's the reason why
women are the ones initiating divorces
because they get into relationships and
they realize hang on a minute this is
actually work this isn't what they
showed me in a Disney movie This is
actually what they showed me in the
rom-com I've actually got work at this
like you know I've got to wake up this
person's farting in the bed and you know
what I mean like all of this kind of
stuff they're burping and all of a
sudden the way they chew food annoys you
you know I mean it's like it's a whole
thing so it's like yeah I think relation
I think men are actually better at
dealing with just being in a Groove in a
relationship than women are I think
women lack a little bit of chaos they
like a little bit more Spicer like
something to
um make them a little bit more excited
whereas men are actually cool with just
being a Groove what do you guys think of
the phrase
if you want I can't remember exactly how
it's phrased but it's like
the worst thing you can do to a woman a
woman is bore her
as a man what do you think of that
that's a bit mad I was afraid the worst
thing you could do to women it might not
be the worst it's just like if you want
her to leave like I can't remember how
they phrased it but it was something
like
like basically it was what they were
trying to say
it's a bit much though I mean in a
relationship like you both kind of get
bored a little bit but like I don't know
that's a bit rude I don't know it's a
bit mad storm but that's the thing I
think women like chaos essentially I
think women like chaos I think they like
to not know what's going on they say
they want stability but when women get
stability they start violent filing for
divorces
it's boring it's like they want you to
they want something more exciting than
this to vanilla yeah it's too vanilla
hmm But actually I have I have a
question for the girls okay would you
rather date
a musician or a
an accountant
she's dated a musician before
you did so you pick musicians
yeah musician okay what about you
um probably the musician as well yeah
what about you Jess I love music so I
would date the musician my watch this
see the musician that's not stability
obviously I could go for the account but
I I love music so like I think it would
be not saying I'd be born with the
Conchas account because love music was
this like a musician no see but it
improves my point yeah like women don't
want stability like that that's the most
unstable job you could possibly have
that's music but we all pick music I
actually watched a tick tock video um
recently with a woman she was on you
know she was speaking to this other guy
and he was like why did you file for
divorce and she was like oh he
he was really good with money and you
know he would save and
um it just it was like he didn't really
want to spend and it's like so he was
the guy was like so he was financially
stable and he was you know good with
money and that's what really pissed you
off she was like yeah he didn't really
want to do anything with the money and
he was always saying we need to save for
a rainy day and I was just like
we can't win bro that's the dumbest
thing I've ever like we can't win like
because he couldn't because he saved
because that probably didn't spend on
what she wanted she wanted him to spend
on the buffoonery that doesn't help
bring in the income yeah I have a
question would you guys go
um so who is their nails done here for
you yeah okay three okay okay
um do any of you get like your makeup
done or anything like lash lifts any of
that
no no no no no okay would you guys go
down in lifestyle so no new clothes no
nails done nothing like that
um so like in a year you might get a
couple new outfits that's it for a
family and you'd have to work twice as
hard and
um
make
like no extra like you'd get no extra
discretional income
for a family would you yes or no oh yeah
yeah of course like I did that for three
years
continuing still now and then I did the
13 years helping family too okay good
good what about you
you go down on lifestyle for a family
yeah yeah
you I don't know how much lower my
lifestyle can get but
my lifestyle is pretty like neutral so
yeah I would go down in it I don't need
my nails done do you women think that
it's talking about divorce you think
it's better for women than it is for men
after divorce
women
is it you're saying do you think it's
better yeah do you think it's better
because I'm I'm gonna read you some some
divorce settlements right so Melinda
Gates when Aaron Bill Gates
um
um divorced she got she's now worth 6.7
billion
Mackenzie Scott who is uh Jeff beans his
ex-wife she's now worth 27.9 billion
Nicole young he was Dr Dre's
um ex-wife she's now worth 100 million
so women get
a lot of money from these divorces and
men get to kind of see their empire
slashed in half and crumble I don't know
I guess there is kind of like a little
bit of like an after rush after being in
a relationship for a long time and you
get out of it whether you know it was
you or the other person stopping it that
is just like this thing where you were
low for
however long your low forward but then
at one point when you get out of that
you do feel almost like new kind of
again I don't know it's just like
it obviously depends on how close you
were with the person but resemble me
recently I felt better also because the
relationship was really toxic but I feel
better getting out of it you know after
going through like that as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible